okay whoever put me on reddit out there
you know I got a bone to pick with you
the plan was to get subscribers at a
torturously slow incremental rate over a
period of decades that was the plan God
some people you know what all I can say
to you is coffee on a Tuesday and vlog
42 so there's a feeling I sometimes get
maybe you get it too that happens for
example when I come around a corner and
all of a sudden I'm confronted by a
sunset or at that moment in a movie when
everything just falls into place hairs
stand up on the back of my neck and a
chill runs down my shoulder at times it
freezes me in place blanks my mind and
the feeling I have is one of
astonishment and awe Jimmy Stewart my
favorite actor describes it like this
creating moments in movies this I think
is the important thing
hmm nobody knows exactly how it happened
turns out there's a name for this
feeling it's called Frieza it's a French
word for cold chill but really there is
no English equivalent in French it's
pronounced like this free zone you can
have free song with a person someone
you're attracted to and if I had to
guess it probably happens most
frequently in that nervous flirtatious
almost unbearable time before any
feelings are expressed outright okay so
have you ever spent a subway ride or a
bus ride sort of on-off looking at
someone from across the Train someone
who is beautiful someone who strikes you
and who you stupidly fall in love with
for the 10 minutes it takes to get from
34th Street to Union Square you look at
them as they look away and then you can
feel their eyes on you as you look away
and then you sort of which is wait there
until you think it's safe though there's
I contacted phrasing for easy reason
maybe it's just me whatever triggers it
we all get these feelings of freezing
one of the most common sources is music
a study published last year in Nature
Neuroscience showed that the moment in
your favorite song when you experience
that chill that feeling of free zone
coincides with the release of the
neurotransmitter dopamine into your
brain opening makes you feel good and
it's commonly released to reinforce or
motivate biologically significant
activity like
or sex suggesting that for some reason
unknown to us music is inextricably
linked to our deepest reward systems but
there's something else see I also get a
feeling of free zone when overwhelmed by
a sad song it's a chill but a kind of
consoling David here on a professor at
Ohio State University and who runs the
cognitive and systematic musicology
laboratory awesome name has this to say
about sad music when a person is in a
sad state this hormone called prolactin
is released and it has a psychological
effect a consoling psychological effect
it's as though the music has put them
into a kind of sham state of sadness and
the body has responded by releasing this
hormone called prolactin and it's it's
like Mother Nature sort of wrapping your
arms around you and consoling you and
saying they're there everything's okay
and you have this kind of warm fuzzy
feeling extremely interesting but
following from that I want to pick up on
an earlier point biologically we really
don't know why music affects us so
powerfully why it gives us those
feelings of free son or consolation or
combination of both but psychologically
I think that music is embedded in each
one of us uniquely strung along our
memories in the way that Christmas
lights are strung along a tree branch to
me music is the raw ore of beauty it
goes deeper and affects a more potent
emotional response than any other art
form it's why when people ask I say that
the Beatles are the artists of any
medium that have had the largest single
influence on me On February 4 2008 NASA
transmitted a song for the first time
into deep space the Beatles across the
universe in the direction of the star
Polaris 431 light-years from Earth it's
always been a sad song for me if not for
its swelling drifting quality then
because it gets me thinking of John
Lennon indeed the idea of melodies like
that dancing out into a silent and
unfeeling universe gives me such a chill
and then such a warmth that I do have
the feeling of being wrapped in a
blanket and I'm consoled for a moment or
a minute of my humanity
welcome to everybody who's new I'm so
glad to have you really this is a good
example of sort of what goes on here the
vlog is is a project of learning but
also of expression trying to say
something
thoughtfully and precisely so on my
channel page you can find social
networks things Twitter Tumblr Facebook
things like that and seriously thank you
to that person who put me on reddit I
owe you a beer or 20,000